Nhiều tài sẽ ngợi ngàn khi bị phạt lối tốc độ trên đại lộ viên cơ lộ.
Theo báo viên năm nay, đại lộ viên cơ lộ với đưa vọa hạt lộ hơi ngụ tháng,
nhưng đã có hàng trăm tài sẽ ổ tổ vi phạt tốc độ,
bị lập biết bản sự phạt hành chính.
Chức đó, đại lộ viên cơ lộ đã được đưa vọa khai thách tạp,
để hăng thiện các khạm một con lại của dễ án đến ngày ba mười tháng mười,
các phần tiện sau thông được phép lưu thông trên tuyền với tốc độ tối đà là nắm 100 kí lơ mát trên rời.
Dù lực lực lực kệng sát sâu thông,
với hông bởi sở thông tổ vực tài tình,
tổ chức tuyền phát tổ rời,
nhắc nhở người dân về được tính đường mới chỉ cho phát trạp tốc độ nông 100 kí lơ mát trên rời.
Tuy nhiên, các tài sẽ còn trị quả tốc độ,
tìm mình viên cơ gây tài nát.
Tương ngay một môi tăng chính,
lực kệng sát sâu thông trật tự đã thức kiện việc tôn chà,
kiểm soát vỗ nhầy hai ca,
nhằm đặt bảo á tàn sâu thông,
trong phòng hai mil năm này qua,
có tới hơn 1 năm mấy tài xế,
trị quả tốc độ bị lập viên bát xử vật hành chính.